french president looked tired but
relaxed as he hosted a video conference
with several charities the meeting came
only hours after the elysee palace
announced that emmanuel macron had
tested positive for covid19
the 42 year old leader plans to keep
working during his seven days of
isolation
he will honor his appointments but with
even more caution than his usual at the
elysee for the president since the start
of the pandemic
in public macro wears a face mask and
takes precautions
but at times he has failed to social
distance
he's attended a number of events in the
past week including an eu summit
he also met several european leaders in
paris including portugal's prime
minister antonia costa
and spanish premier pedro sanchez who
are now self-isolating
in france the prime minister and
macron's wife bridget are in quarantine
several members of the government and
president's party are being tested
it is clear that the message from the
elysee is that it is
business as usual unless mackerel's
condition deteriorates
he will remain in charge throughout his
isolation
the idea is that this doesn't change
anything and
it's not a big deal that's what the
eliza is trying to say
but they are not saying what are the
symptoms that
the president has had we know that he
was tested after
showing symptoms and and we don't know
where those symptoms are the french
government has lifted some lockdown
restrictions
but reimposed a nighttime curfew as the
country continues to battle the pandemic
macron's diagnosis is a sobering
reminder
that anyone can be infected natasha
butler
al jazeera paris